[Música]
a
época
olhar as estrelas do céu
contemplar o universo
e eu fui criada por um
professor chamado Leopoldo de meis eu
fiz mestrado e doutorado com m uma
pessoa diferenciada especial lembro que
quando a gente
estudava os dados nossos resultados e
sempre falava assim Renatinha foi assim
que a natureza aqui
sempre vincular lava tudo que acontecer
em termos de ciência com a natureza
bom e muitas e muitas situações ele
sempre comentava fazer ciência é um
olhar estrelas no céu é contemplar
universo entender as os fenômenos
naturais e promover ações para o bem de
todos sem muito bacana para mim me
emociona falar sobre isso porque eu
trabalhei muitos anos com ele
é com esse olhar com essa visão de que
forma a gente pode entender
como ser humano se relaciona com a
natureza um dos aspectos é a forma com
que ele busca os seus alimentos
e o alimento Ele oferece para o ser
humano
nutrientes e vitaminas minerais as
famosas proteínas carboidratos fibras
bom então move prazer é bom comer é
muito bom tem família é muito bom ter
alimentos prazeroso Eu gosto muito de
falar que alimento ainda uma loucurinha
assim que coisa boa Então Além disso
tudo além dos nutrientes alimento é bom
é gostoso Maravilha só que a produção de
alimentos e esse consumo de alimentos
ela tem necessita ser bom para mim e
para todos o ser humano muitas vezes ele
fala assim ah eu gosto de contemplar Eu
gosto de olhar me sinto bem na natureza
vem a natureza somos nós nós somos nós
fazemos parte de nosso corpo tem relação
né com esse Eco E para isso essa busca
do alimento tem que ser bom para mim e
vão para o eco também
o últimos anos a ciência colocou muito
em Pauta e até hoje
é uma substância chamado substâncias
funcionais ou as alimentos funcionais
e esses alimentos promovem saúde
sensacional são alimentos que são
antioxidantes e
anti-inflamatórios fazem bem para o
intestino enfim tem números compostos
são bióticos e seus compostos vêm os
alimentos principalmente alimentos
naturais
Ah e dessa forma essa ciência que
colocou isso em Pauta que descobriu isso
consegue conectar cada vez mais a busca
da própria saúde do ser humano na
natureza
a outra questão importante em relação
aos alimentos é que eles então precisam
né ser ou fornecer saudabilidade o
chamados alimentos com Label rótulo
Limpo então eu procuro alimentos que
tenham ingredientes naturais que eles
esses igrejas naturais Teoricamente
fazem bem para minha saúde
historicamente não faz bem para minha
saúde dessa forma a gente consegue então
entender que o alimento é mais do que os
nutrientes então ele tem que ser os
nutrientes eles têm que ser gostosos
eles têm que ser naturais
mas tem falta algo que é muito
importante para nossa sobrevivência no
planeta e aí então esse essa visão
a circular do alimento vamos dizer assim
completa quando esse alimento para Além
disso ele é produzido ele é fornecido de
forma que ele faça bem para todos e o
que a gente vai comer no futuro
e se tem todos esses olhares que o
consumidor e sua irmã vai ter que ter
existe hoje diversos estudos a própria
Organização Mundial de Saúde Ela comenta
vários alimentos que tem uma
possibilidade de nos ajudar a manter né
alimentação e principalmente as
proteínas você tá alguns deles um deles
é a proteína de alga a água é uma
possibilidade muito importante de nos
ajudar a ter proteínas e a mais
sustentável do que a produção que a
gente tem hoje em dia no mundo o que o
que a ciência né vamos supor
alternativas e a gente vai escolher a
melhor e se encaixa claro então eu gosto
mais e um relação a todos esses olhares
que eu coloquei não algas é um deles e a
outra também que é bem interessante que
eu acho muito interessante vai vir logo
também que é a agricultura celular eu
vou falar Mais especificamente de carne
cultivada a carne cultivada é a carne
que é produzida que é desenvolvida no
laboratório hoje tem diversos centros de
pesquisa no mundo procurando isso no
Brasil já tem também e logo logo isso
vai ter a gente poder realmente comprar
no mercado vários estudos dizem que a
carne cultivada é mais sustentável
outra alimento bem interessante que vai
vir também logo é são os insetos os
insetos Eles já em diversas culturas né
já utilizam o sexo como fonte de
proteína e a própria recomendação da
Organização Mundial da Saúde também a
fao homens na realidade ela estima na
realidade que os insetos serão os
alimentos do futuro se a arma dos
insetos muitas vezes também tá então os
insetos eles são fontes de proteína e
tem uma produção mais sustentável mais
amiga do Pânico eu dei três exemplos que
a gente vai ver no futuro e que muitas
vezes nós precisamos nos transformar
para oportunizar essas experiências e
fazer com que o homem ou melhor do ser
humano tenha nutrientes mais
sustentáveis porque eu tô falando isso
porque eu comecei lá atrás da questão de
olhar o universo porque quando a gente
faz ciência para todos a gente tem que
pensar dessa forma também a produção de
alimentos
e aí então para além dos saudável para
lenço da habilidade e do trembo tem as
possibilidades de outros vamos ver nomes
ou selos que eu posso buscar nos
alimentos e produtos
eu vou citar alguns deles né Por exemplo
eco-friendly seria alimentos amigos da
natureza amigos do clima
o outro quer ekofootprint que são os
alimentos em relação com diminuição da
emissão de gases que também tem pacto
das mudanças climáticas do planeta entre
outros
dessa forma a gente consegue buscar os
alimentos que fazem vão fazer bem para
mim não fazer bem para mim a geração e
para geração e o futuro de todos nós
e quando a gente entende que isso
acontece quando a gente entende essa
premissa a gente entende essa proposta
de valor a gente muda e transforma o
nosso pensamento quando a gente busca o
alimento da gente consumir Essa
informação tem que a partir das minhas
atitudes de procurar os meus alimentos
com essas valores e essas entregas
e dessa forma então a gente pode voltar
que tudo que a gente faz uma maneira
geral tudo que a gente faz termo de
ciência e todas nossas atitudes tem
relação com o próprio Leopoldo nos
palavras sempre que as nossas ações
baseadas no contemplar a natureza de
olhar as estrelas do céu muito obrigado
a